people's my stomach's been grumbling but
help has arrived
my main man Mookie has saved the day
straight from Sal's famous pizzeria down
the block
speaking to the night Mookie don't be
shy he just smells good
now this is your look daddy talking
starving like Marvin go ahead talk to
the people all right mr. loved-ed I like
to dedicate the next Rickett to my heart
and soul Tina
all right let me play this record while
I'd go to work on my chicken parmigiana
hero with extra cheese and extra salsa
all right here you go and keep the
change
tell your father he still makes the best
he is before you look when the blind
artists a whole section over a full of
lamb meat job joy searing Clarence
Carter ain't got some new stuff over
there hello a white rock group go over
what I call real white stick you'll love
them got another cat over there getting
this brother blankets don't call
yourself sunglasses check them out look
at me cook soon as you pop
next time I may go all over them you
woke me up side and check you out okay
was alright no come on back